Hank: Good morning, John.
John: Good morning, Hank.
Where are- oh it's Fort Awesome!
We must be at the dftba.com warehouse.
Whoa.
Oh where's the camera going?
Hank: Goodbye, camera.
John: It's question Tuesday, the day that
it's- it's- it's- it's- it's question Tuesday,
the day that we answer- it's question Tuesday,
the day that we answer real questions-
Hank: I'm gonna leave all of those in, just
by the way.
John: I know you will, I know you will.
It's question Tuesday, the day that we answer
real questions from real nerdfighters.
Hank: It's Friday!
John: Are you sure that you don't want to
upload this on my day?
Hank: I'm sure.
John: Alright.
Hank : I've just asked on Twitter if people
have any questions for us, John.
Would you like to answer some questions for
people?
John: Yes, that's how question Tuesday and
Friday work.
Hank: Jessica would like to know, "What were
your first cars?"
John: My first car was a 1991 Volvo 240 named
Arlo.
Hank: Funny!
That was my first car, too.
[John laughs]
Hank: Actually, uh, after Arlo, uh, got the
same car again, but, uh, white...
John: White.
Hank: ...and smelled more like vomit.
John: Hank, how, after so long, have you guys
not gotten tired of each other?
Hank: Oh, I'm so tired of you.
John: My question is, how, after all this
time, have you guys not gotten tired of us.
[Hank laughs]
Hank: Hey, John.
John: Yes?
Hank: Evelyn would like to know, "How do you
find a nerdfighter at your university?
John: One of my favorite ways is to wear some
kind of, uh, nerdfighter clothing because
that tends to attract them.
Lots of colleges now have nerdfighter clubs.
Hank: And if you don't have a nerdfighter
club at your university, you should start
one.
John: You can start one.
Michaela asks, "Who is playing Margo in the
Paper Towns movie?"
Hank?
Hank: Uh, I am.
John: Yes!
We have been begging Hank.
There is no other Margo Roth Spiegelman.
That's what we've been saying.
It's not a passion project for Hank.
It's just...
Hank: I'm really not interested in the project
itself.
John: ...purely financial.
Hank: I'm the Nick Cage of John Green movies.
I'll do any John Green movie as long as you
pay me enough.
[John laughs]
John: Poor Nick Cage.
Oh, God.
Hank: Hopefully, he doesn't watch.
John: He's-
Hank: I am a huge Nick Cage fan, actually.
"This wood is fake."
John: That Christopher Walken?
Hank: No, that was Nick Cage from Moonstruck.
John: Is that Jack- Jack Nicholson?
Hank: How about you sing the answer to the
next question?
[John grunts.]
John: Yes.
Hank: Hey, John.
John: Yes?
Hank: Beth would like to know, will she be
able to buy one of those posters you signed?
John: Yeeessss.
Is that how you sing?
Hank: We are at the warehouse right now because
John's been signing posters all day and I've
just been watching him.
John: By the way, dftba.com, link in the dooblydoo.
Or just go to dftba.com, you can just type
it, just five letters.
John: Hannah asks "Any advice on strengthening
relationships between siblings?"
Hank: Make a video blog together.
John: I am a big believer, actually, in shared
projects, like Hank and I are a lot closer
because we do stuff together.
Hank: I think that goes for most relationships.
John: Henry and I were just making Legos and
it's so fun!
Hank: Yeah, like yeah.
Father son-
John: He wasn't really doing anything.
Hank: Right, you made Legos and he-
John: And he was like "Go, dad.
Do it" And then he would be like "That's the
bad guy."
And I'd be like "I don't know.
I mean aren't villains complicated?
Isn't it - you know we don't know that person's
backstory; we need to learn to imagine them
complexly", and Henry would say "He's REALLY
bad."
[Hank laughs]
Hank: I have a question.
John: Yeah.
Hank: Tell me some more stuff Henry says.
[John laughs]
John: I will tell you one more thing; we're
emphasizing learning, how like knowledge is
power, Henry said to Sarah the other day "You
know what's a good kind of learning?"
and Sarah said "What?" and Henry said "Learning
how to turn on the TV."
[John laughs]
Hank: How does Henry feel about me?
Is he a fan of Hank?
John: Yeah, no, he said right before I left
to come about here, he said "I would like
you to give a message to Uncle Hank and Auntie
Katherine, okaboasdsanfdeanrokloghahhh.".
[John and Hank laugh]
Hank: I'm glad - well I'm glad that that message
got passed on.
John: It was literally the last thing he said
to me before I left, so and I was waiting,
you know I was waiting like I love them, I
miss them, I can't wait to see them, okasafdseslknrtksdfn.
Hank: He probably watched my videos and he
knows that that's how I talk.
[John laughs]
Hank: John.
John: Yes.
Hank: Thank you for doing question Tuesday
with me.
John: It has been my pleasure.
Hank: I'll see you on Tuesday but also...
John and Hank: ...now.
Hank: It was good.
John: The world may be broken, but hope is
not crazy.
I love unironic enthusiasm.
Hank: How do you express your unironic enthusiasm?
John: Gigigigigigigigigigigigigi generally.
Some version of that.
Sometimes it's internal.
Hank: Can I try?
John: Yeah.
Hank: Gigigigigigigigigigigigigi!
John: That's much better than your Nicholas
Cage impression.
Now you have to put it in the video!
[Hank Laughs]